remember that scene
brad pitt shirtless and sweaty on the
roof
in his 2019 flick once upon a time in
hollywood
yeah me too anyway
get ready to pick your chin up off the
floor again because brad
just blessed us with a new shirtless
moment
and let's just say 2021 is off to a
great start
it's good it was really good it's a good
time the 57 year old actor
kicked off the new year in turks and
caicos with his pal
red hot chili peppers rocker flea and
was spotted on a boat heading off to do
some snorkeling
looking ten shades of fire
that's brad sporting goggles and swim
trunks
and looking every bit the bad boy with
his tats
on full display and
i'm drooling i'm pretty grateful for
that can we just sidebar for a second
this photo is proof that brad pitt is
the hottest
man on the planet because no one and
i mean no one looks sexy in snorkeling
goggles
and he legit just achieved the
impossible people
nice brad nice it's just it's pure
celebration of
life anyway brad and flee
appear to be in the same germ circle
amid the coronavirus pandemic
because they were also spotted together
back in may when the oscar winner was
seen checking out the 58 year old
musician's motorcycle in malibu
and i just gotta say brad made 2020 a
little more bearable
not only did he make all of our dreams
come true when he platonically reunited
with his ex jennifer aniston
everyone is waiting they're hoping for
this moment where you and jennifer run
into each other so they can take their
picture
i'll run into jen she's a good friend
yeah yeah so they can
you know you know how this goes the
second the second most
important reunion ever of of her year
exactly you know how that works on
friends and then they were saying that
anyways but he also gave us all the
feels in november when he spent the day
handing out boxes of groceries to
low-income families in south central l.a
plus who could forget when brad brought
the lols with his now iconic impression
of dr fauci on saturday night live
good evening i'm dr anthony fauci
first i'd like to thank all the older
women in america who have
sent me supportive inspiring and
sometimes graphic emails
so brad on behalf of literally
everyone thank you for your service it's
really delightful
[Music]
you